He learned yesterday that Republican Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell held up the
passage of the Corona virus stimulus bill
that the Senate ultimately approved and the
House is presumably going to approve today
and maybe by the time you listen to this,
they already have Mitch McConnell held it
up for an additional unnecessary 10 days.
Now, I would actually go even further and
I said this before.
And in fact, now the pandemic response playbook
that was left behind for the Trump administration
by the Obama administration says the same
thing.
They should have started working on the stimulus
package weeks ago, probably even even a couple
of months ago, ahead of the curve starting
to climb.
Instead of creating this panic behind always
behind the curve situation, which ultimately
is what develop.
But we've long lost that battle.
Let's forget about that.
What we know is that in practice, Mitch McConnell
could have moved this thing through the Senate
far faster than he did.
The conservative assessment is that there
were 10 unnecessary days of delay here.
Senate agrees.
Goes to the House, presumably for a vote today.
So yesterday, Mitch McConnell does a press
conference about the bill.
First question comes from a female reporter.
And it's a very good question, which we'll
get to in a second.
Mitch McConnell puts this dumb looking expression
on his face and then he responds by saying
to her, do you work here?
Take a look at the clip.
Understand, of course, this is a crisis.
And time is of the essence.
This vote began and the public had not yet
seen the bill.
Lobbyists had seen the bill and none of the
debate had been held in public.
There is virtually no public debate on what
looks to be the largest bill in American history.
Can you explain why that was?
And should the public have had more time to
understand what this bill is that is meant
to help that new worker saga where the elected
representatives of the American people.
Do you work here?
She correctly points out you voted.
The bill wasn't made public.
Lobbyists saw it.
The public wasn't able to actually see any
of the debate because the debate wasn't public.
The public wasn't able to look at the bill
and then call lawmakers and say, hey, what
about this?
What about that?
Which is part of the system that we have where
the public gets that way in on what it is
that is going to be passed, 10 days of a delay
and still without the public debate, without
the time during which the bill could have
been reviewed.
No opportunity for the public to even attempt
to lobby their members of Congress.
And Mitch McConnell's answer is, do you work
here?
This guy who ran the impeachment hearings
like a clown show.
I mean, really a kangaroo court.
The same guy who delayed, delayed, delayed.
And now Americans may be in three weeks.
Some Americans will start getting a twelve
hundred dollar check instead of being days
away.
If Mitch McConnell had gotten this done 10
days ago, he's asked a real substantive question.
And his reaction is, do you work here?
We've got to get that seat back.
Guys, we've.
We have to remove Mitch McConnell.
There is an opponent.
Mitch McConnell has an opponent.
Amy Magrath running against him.
Former Marine fighter pilot was a Democratic
congressional nominee back in 2018.
This is this could be a fight.
It's going to be an uphill battle.
There are recent polls that show they are
running close.
We know that when you have the power of incumbency,
once that sweet, sweet Republican national
money starts pouring in for Mitch McConnell,
it's going to be an uphill battle for Amy
MCGRATH.
I don't pretend it's going to be anything
otherwise, but to January, polls have it very
close.
And in the end, we have a real opportunity
here not just to remove any Republican senator
and turn the seat blue, not just the opportunity
to remove the Senate majority leader by turning
a seat blue.
We have the opportunity to remove what has
been what who the person who has been one
of the most effective Republican tools.
And I don't mean tool, you know, as an ad
hominem.
He's been a tool of the Republican Party effectively
doing work for them for a very, very long
time.
And as I've said before, I always want to
have clarity when I bring this up, when I
say make.
Mitch McConnell has been incredibly successful.
It's doing all things I find disgusting.
But when you look at Mitch McConnell's role
in holding up the Merrick Garland Supreme
Court nominees at nomination during Barack
Obama, leading to Donald Trump getting to
put Neil Gorsuch on the court, if you're a
Republican, that's a massive accomplishment.
Look at all of the judges that Mitch McConnell
has successfully sort of shepherded through
Senate confirmation and gotten installed in
lifetime positions, allowing Donald Trump
and prior Republicans to mold the judiciary
for decades to come.
This is one of the most successful and efficient
operators doing all terrible things.
So if you're.
Looking for it, you know, we don't know exactly
what's going to happen with the virus.
We don't know when and how these campaigns,
including the Senate campaign, presidential,
etc., are going to resume and in what form.
But at a certain point, you'll probably be
able to phone bank for Amy McGraugh and at
a certain point, there still will be these
campaigns being fought one way or the other.
This is a good one.
Mitch McConnell against Amy Magrath and really
working two to see if we can make this a reality.
It would be an incredible coup to be able
to remove Mitch McConnell.